good afternoon my name is Jared Cohen
I'm the president Carnegie Mellon it's
my great pleasure to welcome you here to
this special ceremony an event where we
are going to celebrate an honor to very
dedicated alumni and university leaders
at Frank and Sarah rachie it's reason
enough just their existence and all that
they do as university leaders and
supporters to have the celebration but
in addition they made a wonderful gift
it creates the fund for art at the
frontier a wonderful name which will
support artistic exploration at the
borders and the intersections of
disciplines the the college of fine arts
studio for creative inquiry will be
central to all of this it will be the
organization that oversees this fund and
identifies and supports projects that we
funded from the fund and a recognition
of this gift I'm very pleased to tell
you that this year will be renamed that
Frank Reggie studio for creative inquiry
I don't think anybody represents the
diverse skills of Carnegie Mellon board
more than ed and Sara do as you know ed
was a computer science graduate he's a
vice president at apple today and so he
kind of took the left brain side of
things and Sarah although I although I i
have trouble describing one side of the
other one on you and
and and Sarah who graduated with her
bachelor's degree in the arts from
Carnegie Mellon is an accomplished
painter and if you've ever wondered what
happens when you bring together the two
sides of Carnegie Mellon's wonderful
skill and diversity the Arts and
Technology you'll see what you get in
Edna Sarah's daughters witten who
graduated in 2006 with an
interdisciplinary degree in humanities
and the arts from Carnegie Mellon is an
actress today and their daughter naomi
is an artist and musician
thank you it Nanami and thanks to all of
you for joining us here today what you
just experienced or is it turned out
might not have experienced was a
performance of John Cage's four minutes
33 seconds the coats the lighting who
performed the piece and whether the
piece was performed at all we're all
determined by roll of the dice not
randomness of probability the coats the
lighting of the performer were all
probability one-half events well I
decided ahead of time that the
probability of performing the piece at
all today would be a 56 event
probability event so if you didn't see
or experience the peace today it was
only modestly likely that you didn't
further given that it was very early in
the campaign that we committed to make
our gift is a probability 1 10th event
that we're here today celebrating her
gift during the hundredth anniversary of
the birth of John Cage he created
exactly the kind of art that we hoped
his developed through the Frank rachie
studio and the fund for art at the
frontier thus it is appropriate to
perform 433 today because during his
life cage truly was one of the pioneers
of the frontier of contemporary
performance in naming the studio and
creating our fund our goal is this for
Carnegie Mellon the carnival community
to challenge and expand current forms of
artistic expression to my way of
thinking art has been as critical as
science and engineering in moving humans
along the probabilistic path we travel
however well it is easy to see the
evolutionary benefit of safe figuring
out going to move water from here to
there it's a little less obvious why
humans write poetry paint beautiful
paintings dancing and do all the other
things we call our yet when you look at
the time energy and money we spend on
these things it is clear that art is
extremely important that artistic
expression is indeed fundamental to
human
in that that we would not be human
without it because it very much defines
what it means to be human it is in this
spirit that we were giving this gift at
Carnegie Mellon we want to ensure that
as well as being at the forefront of
engineering and science that Carnegie
Mellon is at the forefront of the
evolution of artistic expression and in
a very deep sense at the forefront of
the evolution of humanity thank you
thank you Sarah and then for n Naomi and
witten for what we're doing this morning
for this gift and what it means to the
school it's an extraordinarily powerful
gift for the College of Fine Arts for
several reasons not the least of which
examined here this morning in this
opportunity to to think and be part of
an artistic expression it absolutely
expands the opportunities our students
have to learn by doing especially those
who are exploring the boundaries of
traditional art and culture it also
strengthens our commitment to research
and creative exploration at the
intersection of Arts and Technology
certainly the studio is an important
locus for this and this kind of activity
is a strategic priority for the studio
we believe this gift will inspire even a
greater number of students and faculty
across campus to come to us to look at
these innovative and inventive
collaborative opportunities and to
expand what art and culture means in our
society today it's my great pleasure to
to thank ed Sarah for the creation of
the Frank rachie fund for our frontier
and I thought we should take a moment to
talk about what we're going to do with
it and how it will affect us here its
primary purposes are to encourage and to
support the creation of new arts
research by the faculty staff and
students of carnegie mellon university
in order to build a cache of
high-quality artworks developed here at
carnegie mellon innovative works that
can be described as thinking at the
edges and intersections of disciplines
the fund will fund at least five
projects every year to be selected by a
five-person committee which itself spans
the college of fine arts in university
and the city and it will do so I'm so
happy and proud to say in perpetuity
in my humble opinion our work
exemplifies the convergence of the two
cultures so often boasted by Carnegie
Mellon as a documentary filmmaker I'm
interested in stories of invention and
discovery how people shape new tools and
how those tools become integral of the
creative process inspiring new
potentials for aesthetic exploration
when i joined the studio it was my
objective to make documentary videos to
share stories from inside the lab to
investigate the relationship between
culture and technology from the
perspective of the creative people who
are really shaping the future i believe
that documentary serves as a powerful
educational tool for outreach to
communicate the work we do and inspire a
sense of wonder through this work I have
begun to rethink the meeting with video
itself experimenting with new filmmaking
techniques none of this work would have
been possible without an environment as
supportive and open to interdisciplinary
and anti disciplinary research as the
studio joining the studio you become
part of the family Marge Linda Dan
Annika amisha Alex Caitlin than gold
it's the kind of place that's buzzing 18
hours a day and everyone who works there
I think couldn't imagine a more dynamic
and stimulating environment thanks to
this generous gift from mr. Frank and
Miss barrace the fellows our lab can
continue discovering new forms of
creative expression at the frontiers of
video I hope that the work and ideas
thought about attempted researched and
created in the studio will also
continually bump against convention and
viewers I encourage the students and
faculty to think expansively experiment
take many leaps towards a dream to fail
be brave and create students from all
the schools should understand the studio
will be a welcoming place to find
support and help in the process of
making art that could move boundaries
could clarify and distort contemporary
culture in profound ways Sarah in it I
think you can be confident that your
gift will result in all the things that
Sarah just mentioned and hopeful but it
has already produced something in
addition which is excitement and hope
for the future of the Arts here at
carnegie mellon not that it was hopeless
I'm going to be wrong
but it's not an area that gets the the
kind of support it deserves often enough
and so we are especially grateful for
this gift this very thoughtful
insightful and exciting gift please join
me in thanking a dancer
you